hi my name is Chris Harvey and from
deloitte and I'm the global head of
Deloitte's financial services business
I'm going to ask answer a question on
what could I a student from high school
do to support the economy of my country
and this is a question from king alex
178 so hiking Alex and I think the most
important thing you can do to support
the growth of your country's economy is
to go and work in business and business
plays a crucial role in society and
creating jobs creating wellness and
creating social stability so without
doubt Alex the best thing you could do
is to go and work in in the business
sector in the commercial sector I think
the thing that concerns me most is when
I go around high schools and colleges
around the world and I see young people
like you who want to go into government
service and I think that's okay but
actually what really makes the world go
around is business so my advice to you
and my advice or anybody else who wants
to look at this is that the best thing
you can do for your country for your
economy is to go into the business
sector and to create wealth create jobs
for other people and and ensure that
society remains stable and and growing